et voilà un bon kilo g d'épinards
c'est pas pour faire de la cuisine c'est
pour réaliser une photographie à la
chlorophylle pour fixer ce moment
historique
non le confinement ne montrent pas la
tête c'est pour obtenir un ante au type
à l'est/sud-est moi je vous montrais la
recette
d'abord vous y croisez des feuilles
d'épinard mélangé avec de l'eau pour en
extraire le jus un jus bien vert qui
contient de la chlorophylle
mais pas que puis vous enduisez une
feuille de papier à dessin
avec ce jeu quand c'est bien sec vous
humidifié puis vous déposez la
silhouette que vous souhaitez reproduire
une monture de lunettes par exemple que
vous recouvrez avec une feuille de
plexiglas vous mettez le tout au soleil
ce thermostat
on s'en fiche l'important c'est la lune
vous laissez reposer 15 minutes à 9
heures tout dépend de l'ensoleillement
puis vous retirer la plaque de plexiglas
le masque et vous obtenez un an totti
que s'est il passé ça ne se voit pas
mais le jus d'épinards contient
plusieurs types de pigments la
chlorophylle masquer tous les autres
exposés à la lumière et 7 chlorophylle
se dégrade
on voit alors apparaître une couleur
brune ranger c'est un mélange qui
contient des pigments qu'on ne voyait
pas jusqu'à présent de la carotène
notamment à l'emplacement de la monture
de lunettes
la couleur est resté vert foncé tout
simplement parce que cette zone est
resté à l'abri de la lumière la
chlorophylle ne s'est pas dégradée et
tient au fait dans tous types on
retrouve la racine grecque
anto ce qui signifie fleur si vous
voulez conserver votre équipe
mettez le à l'abri de la lumière car
comme les fleurs c'est périssable à
demain et n'oubliez pas nous sommes
confinés
mais en restant lien si vous avez aimé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à laisser un
pouce bleu vous pouvez également voir ou
revoir toutes celles des jours
précédents cliquant sur le côté gauche
gens publient une chaque jour et pour
être sûr de ne louper aucune et bien
abonnez vous et activer la petite cloche